that's going Reza welcome back to some
more South Park today we're gonna prove
that Becca is a two-faced son of a [ __ ]
alright so here we are where is that
Becca [ __ ] if you want the bushes and
whisper romantic thanks for you to say
why the hell would you do that where the
[ __ ] is Monica it has to be this [ __ ]
yeah are you Monica you must be Mike
yeah whatever so you want to talk about
Betty huh look baby's my friend I think
she's really great I don't want you to
end all be all of girls I mean she's a
little two-faced to gas me a lot of your
facebook profile it I think you're a
really interesting boy stop it thank God
we sent the new kid to spy on you huh
girls and why are you hitting on my
facebook boyfriend we brought someone
else who might be interested Monica what
the [ __ ] are you doing
uh-oh hey Jake have fun you two pay
skank
nice wait please come back what's the
big idea trying to [ __ ] my girlfriend
nothing to say sorry if we're trying to
[ __ ] your girlfriend
now we're gonna [ __ ] your bite let's
circumcise that little [ __ ] so you
won't [ __ ] anyone no more I think that's
how circumcised work or may know that's
abortion
now wait I'm confused all right let's
see what he can do you have the brown
note I want to do the brown note oh damn
[Music]
it's all random [ __ ] all right
power to the people and the brown people
thank God
Monica's mine you Fred she sent any
message what is it
shut up I'm sorry that Jake freaked out
like that but I'd love to be free that's
[ __ ] [ __ ] that skank
alright we need to go to all right let's
go back city ha yes girls wanna thank
you for your help we can go too
alright then let's go you know the drill
alright okay it's goddamn got a gig this
guy's my faith and shade I don't
understand why I got a duty shame hey
Joey
thank you for helping us determine
whether or not Monica was a two-faced
[ __ ] she really made us mad but it
turns out she couldn't have been the one
spreading rumors about Ali Nelson going
to the abortion clinic
what so we made up you guys are the best
you see the thing is Heidi Turner was
supposed to put on the Facebook page
that you were babies boyfriend but she
didn't right so we need to know if Heidi
Turner is the two-faced [ __ ] who's
spreading rumors about Ali being spotted
at the abortion clinic but in order to
do that we need people to think you're a
girl yes this is the moment I be
I've been waiting for this so long oh my
gosh starting
[Music]
yes I can choose to whatever I want
oh my god I'm a [ __ ] got a match that
thing so how the [ __ ] am I supposed to
know oh that's [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah I don't
understand okay we wanted to get you to
make it complete let's get to the quest
what do they give me to be complete get
inside the abortion clinic and find the
records room take a picture of all the
records from the past week and text them
to us that will help us find out who the
toothpaste [ __ ] I'm sure you can
appreciate why none of us can do this if
any of us are spotted in there people
might think we're [ __ ] like Jessica
Rodriguez hey guys what are you up to
oh nothing just finding out which of our
friends is a two-faced [ __ ] cool we'll
see your own awesome skank all right
find out if Jesse had an abortion do
[ __ ]
I'm missus
sir I could swear I heard a voice coming
up from the sewers it said something
like hurry okay so what's our quest
speak in their section estava clinic OD
how Freudian 45 that's how people when
they say my name okay so we're going to
see if she's a skank or not she send me
a message whatever she says I like you
don't name call someone behind there but
you don't name then act like you're
their best friend not like all other
[ __ ] I'm friends with okay Jessica
thank you let's go and get our new nose
I can't wait to get my hey so Hoffa here
for an abortion okay don't be scared the
first one's always the scariest take
room a second door to your left no don't
don't tell me then we're gonna do what I
think we're gonna do why does no I'm
sorry your little friend will have to
wait out here here's my services won't
be needed here you go ahead I don't like
where this is going man I whoa
okay I'm just gonna say you might not
want to watch further than this okay
[Music]
disguise yourself as doctor please don't
make me good what the [ __ ] hi I'm dr.
poon lover get on up in the chair and
this won't take long at all Hey a little
young to be having an abortion aren't we
it's okay we have a booster seat all
right just sit back and relax oh here we
go
ah what what the Wow never seen that
before you burned out the vacuum I'm
gonna have to get this thing fixed
because a [ __ ] vacuum there's so much
wrong with this I don't even know okay
that wasn't too bad I thought was gonna
be worse
I remember the episode where mrs. mr.
Gary there's a sex change or whatever
and that's that's his [ __ ] girls man
there's some girls [ __ ] all right can we
disguise ourselves now is that a do we
even have that I do I need to pick up
[ __ ] in Multan - yeah we got 2013 oh uh
iPhone that [ __ ] damn it that was hey
do you thank God something strange is
going on here the PTA reviewed that tape
you got us the Taco Bell has something
called a plan B they've been here
looking through these records but why
would they be interested in the
gynecological files of the women of
South Park I'm afraid now you know too
much oh no we have two more asking a lot
of questions deal with them quietly we
can't let anyone find out what we were
doing there before you kill us tell us
why why is Taco Bell taking the records
of women's vaginas in South Park I'm
picking up some hot readings on the
Peggy tell us what do women's vaginas
and Doritos Locos Tacos have in common
going crazy what [ __ ] there's an
outbreak here we have contamination in
Sector seven all units to sector seven
now why care the entire building put
that woman in restraints what's going on
at Taco Bell's security your clinic is
infected with a nazi zombie virus nazi
zombies that's ridiculous and bigoted I
happened to be German one of that
[Laughter]
that's horrible
I didn't laugh at all hey I think if
your job when you're watching this don't
be a fan that it could have been Swedish
and you wouldn't even know about it okay
what the [ __ ] watch out dude a bunch of
soldiers oh you tell me that now now
when I'm kawaii and [ __ ] what are you
guys here a youth syringe that you never
know when that might come in handy and
[ __ ]
by oh I can become a little know me new
here should we try that I mean why not
how do I use that I never used it before
[Music]
god dammit not good really [ __ ]
really let's see if we can use this I
never tried it
wait I don't have any mana I can't see
some mana potion I was at mana high
whatever Hey and now he's use that
battle ball we got another attack
awesome yeah why not
oh he's almost dead holy [ __ ] alright
here we go
that was the bet maybe I actually am
supposed to go hey it would seem like it
Oh what no no Nazi gnomes what the fun
it's really important that you get the
first hit how is this Ihnen resisted
what the [ __ ] half [ __ ] it can't be that
bad it's awesome
finish him back
[Music]
that's what you [ __ ] get [ __ ] oh
okay that's kind of cool
I could have just used that got a fart
here though don't show pay I'm Swedish
and and said I'm innocent that's what I
said
no more sex scenes please awful [ __ ] say
what what what am I looking at here are
we gonna crawl inside his M I don't know
oh it's Randy oh what's going on I'm
just here for an operation oh there you
are doctor I'm ready when you are
is this going to hurt doctor teehee
there's something fishy going on here I
think they might be Nazis on this we'll
see if you're a real doctor or an
abortion do it I wanna fight oh goodness
what if I turned left Christmastime is
once a year every critter holds a deer
every
big or small Christmas you know that
stinks
come on aim for his balls you oh my
balls my mom oh my favorite shopping
malls I'll close it five doctor can we
please get this all right now mash and-2
delayed right how about what nothing's
happening
oh okay I get a oh that's cold that's
cold
this is about as wide as I can character
okay okay to it I'm ready do why what
the [ __ ] man you're missing I don't know
what you're vacuuming right now but
that's not that's all Oh haze into it I
told you that thing isn't a doctor
I could have lived without seeing that
[ __ ]
ah what in the heavens no more balls oh
boy
for [ __ ] sake did it alright so here's
a real doctor oh how did I do it oh yes
get out now you're welcome by the way
you go ahead might be a while before I
can walk very well okay
you look very pretty what the hell is
that
ah Mather's where did you find the alien
goo broken vials were in the trashcan
sir
what could have come into contact with
it in the trash can
that is so wrong mad ok thanks - can we
please kill them please kill them please
kill them now what I was research
shut up
I don't know baby
[Music]
okay of course I have to be small I'm so
dumb all right here we go let's kill
these [ __ ] Nazis [ __ ] well I think
that but it don't [ __ ] I'm just
kidding okay we why don't we don't want
to use that
I hope that level up to about us that
sure was fun what do we do okay that
looks great
cool well it's so cute
did we have to kill it I don't want to
kill it why does you're killing oh it's
already that so disgusting what what are
we walking inside now little pirate my
little e sempre river that's that's good
to know
good times alright we made it
how the hell did we survive that fall
that is the big question
oh [ __ ] Taco Bell huh hey I'll be fine
I know what I'm doing okay alright let's
see here we have a teleporter yes I see
it we turn away this and then we
teleport there and then we go there
there's a Pokemon there that gasps
something annoying
[Music]
okay we got it
teleport shoot go those effects get the
Shippo mouth and then we can pass
wonderful wonderful there we go
I know more now more that defense
mechanism
Oh [ __ ] sake that's disgusting
ah the healing [ __ ] we need a good
attack on these [ __ ] and by good
attack I mean if plagues of eat I don't
care if its weak
that's not so weak if you ask me baby
alright professor chaos those [ __ ]
[Music]
you're [ __ ] nasties that was pretty
close all the shame wow that was really
nice
waiting room that's it that's it the
area secure
code GREEN really not secure
hello units the outbreak has been
contained it's not contained
why not hell are you talking about it's
not contained you don't understand huh
Khloe Kardashian was in here this
morning she had the biggest portion I've
ever seen my my look at the time
I'm ten steps in here Bruce hope you
enjoy watching as always it's a lot of
fun playing fun of you if you enjoy
watching please leave a like it helps to
support this series and it may like
medicine me know that you like it
it's simple inside so without further
ado I'll see you tomorrow
maybe breasts
[Music]